120 000 citoyens français.
Nous avons deux reportages :
Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair à Metz,
et Elyse Allard à Montréal.
- En ce dernier
sprint de campagne, tous
les efforts sont bienvenus.
Les bénévoles s'activent
pour convaincre les indécis,
comme cet homme, qui ira voter,
mais sans grand enthousiasme.
CHRISTIAN, électeur
- Écoeuré par leuré par le syst.
Il y a des gens qui travaillent,
qui ont des fois deux boulots,
jour et nuit, et qui y arrivent
pas, quoi. Ils ont des enfants,
... perdus,
ils sont largués.
- Il viendra en hologramme.
- Ces militants du parti
de gauche radicale La France
insoumise de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
l'admettent. Ils rencontrent
cette année de nombreux Français
qui n'ont même pas l'intention
de participer à l'élection.JEROt
de La France insoumise
- Les gens nous disent
qu'ils sont pas intéressés par
la politique parce qu'ils disent
que ça ne sert à rien d'aller
voter. Et moi, je leur explique
gentiment que oui, non, qu'on
peut avoir des avancées sociales
et que oui, la politique,
c'est aussi quelque chose
qui doit les intéresser.
- Il y a cinq ans, un grand
nombre de Français se sont
abstenus lors du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle.
Ici, à Metz, dans l'est
de la France, le tiers
des électeurs ne se sont pas
présentés aux urnes. Si on se
fie aux sondages, l'abstention
pourrait être encore plus
importante cette année.
XAVIER BOUVET,
conseiller municipal à Metz
- Cette campagne, qui a été
victime d'une actualité de plus
en plus vertigineuse, vient se
surajouter à la crise sanitaire,
d'une part, et puis la crise
citoyenne, d'autre part.
Et sans surprise, on va
assister à des élections
un peu par défaut.
- Xavier Bouvet,
conseiller municipal à Metz,
est témoin du désenchantement
d'une partie de l'électorat.
Selon lui, il n'y a pas
eu d'intérêt
suscité par la campagne
qui explique le phénomène.
- C'est une fatigue démocratique
qui a des racines qui sont
profondes, qui est nourrie
à la fois par une forme
d'incompréhension du système
politique, des temps de
décisions, des com
administratives. Tout ça,
pendant des années, a convergé
pour produire de l'éloignement.
- Manque d'intérêt ou de
motivation, le phénomène touche
particulièrement les jeunes
électeurs. Selon des sondages,
jusqu'à 40% d'entre eux
pourraient bouder les bureaux
de scrutin, dimanche.
- Moi, je sais que je vote pas.
Il y en a sûrement qui fon
pareil que moi et, du coup,
ça fausse les résultats,
on va dire.
- Pour ce militant
de Greenpeace, le manque
d'attention porté par
les candidats à certains thèmes,
comme le climat, né.
MAMADOU KARIM SISSOKO, chef
d'équipe, Greenpeace France
- L'écologie est toujours
reléguée plan. plan. plan. plan.
Pourtant, c'est un sujet qui
peut être mobilisateur aussi,
notamment au niveau des jeunes.
- Sur ce campus, certains
évoquent aussi un système
et des enjeux pas toujours
simples à saisir.
- C'est compliqué de
comprendre tout ce qui se dit
entre tous les candidats.
- Mikaela utilisera
donc cette application,
qui l'aidera à mître
les candidats et leur programme
et ainsi faire son choix.
Tous les moyens sont bons
pour convaincre les électeurs
réticents ou hésitants.
- C'est très problématique
pour la démocratie.
On nous offre le droit de vote,
c'est notre seule arme et,
si personne ne l'utilise,
tout le monde râlera encore
et... et voilà.
- Candidate invisible
à la prle,
l'abstention pourrait
grandement influen